[Music]
[Applause]
not to be able to eat much for the rest
of the day hey guys yes
[Applause]
we're back
hey guys welcome baby Joe we are here to
bring truth and Justice the Spear of
truth shall be thrust into the hearts
and Minds not physically in a way that I
mean you know metaphorical way we are
all domestic terrorists because that's
that is dude oh look at the phrase right
the spirit that spear tip let's address
the elephant in the room
it's pride month well you just call me
fat bro no no
I've been doing so good I'm I'm
you did kind of food shape me I'm going
I did oh don't say that to your audience
they're gonna go crazy I'm sitting here
with the croissant okay and then I admit
it was a mistake God damn brought
croissants because it's Ian's birthday
and we'd love that for him
and it's 500 calories and I [__]
beast modeed that which was a huge
mistake
but um his song called me an elephant I
did not say okay don't lie the elephant
in the room I didn't say that I said
what did I say I said all right are you
really gonna eat that
you know that's what I said which and
now you've been now you have been
Googling how many calories a chocolate
croissant is and I I already knew it was
freaking out about it that's why we're
20 minutes late like 500 calories can
you imagine I mean yeah I didn't even
feel that no it's crazy it's like 100
like 555 calories is basically the
the calorie of a Big Mac I would have
way rather had a Big Mac yeah
you know that's why that's why you gotta
always remember you know making good
food choices but you're doing great you
look good thank you feel good yeah I do
not since that not since I ate that uh
even the fact that you feel kind of bad
oh my God I don't want to get in there
go ahead well in my personal experience
and everyone's different and I'm not
like you know trigger warning for uh
those with uh eating disorders
but in my experience
um when I'm very very strict about my
diet and I'm very serious about it
I notice myself feeling maybe a level of
anxiety when I eat something that I I
that is not in my calories or maybe
that's going to like distort my daily uh
daily uh macro breakdown
and that anxiety a little bit of anxiety
in that regard at least implies that you
you are you know you care about your
health but there's nothing to worry
about there's nothing to worry about now
you just cut off that's like a thing
that's like saying a murderer feels bad
so that's good for them no you don't
don't compare the murder I mean look I
have some delicious treats every now and
then as long as you know
as long as you don't do it again or as
long as you uh ever do that again yeah
no as long as you no as long as you
trade it off with something else that
you were going to have tonight yeah that
sucks because I want to eat dinner but
now I can't no yesterday
what I'm gonna do now is cook a
delicious meal and I'm gonna just smell
it
I'm only gonna smell it and I'm gonna
throw it out because I can't eat it
anymore because I had to eat a chocolate
[__] cough you're gonna get canceled
by eating uh disorder I'm gonna cook a
beautiful steak perfect sear sauteed and
butter you're gonna have age okay well
I'm gonna smell it it's gonna be like a
thousand calories well I'm not gonna eat
it it doesn't matter I'm just gonna
smell it no how many calories am I punch
how many calories you eat a day do you
have any idea
it's probably around 1400. there's no
shot you eat 1400 calories I don't know
what to tell you brother at least 2 000
calories a day you are crazy 100 do not
die that's like eight almonds
no no I ate like 1400 calories a day
no shot you really need to start locking
I haven't even been exercising you need
to start but that's fine you don't like
technically in order to lose weight you
don't really need to exercise it just
like makes it harder it's not healthy
it's like 14 it's like 1400. that's a
severe deficit easy 15 pages that's what
I'm trying to do how many pounds have
you been losing a week
um it varies but maybe like one or two
that's that's actually that actually is
healthy but that's possibly because you
have very sedentary lifestyle I would
recommend being a little bit more stop
insulting me what having a sedentary
lifestyle is what I have as well the
[__] you call me an elephant and then
you call me sedative
that's crazy
come on you are very good don't call me
sedentary
sedentary is not a dis it just means
fossil in the Earth for you to unearth
what Senator just means you don't move
around what that means I know
like I just been in the Earth for a
billion years yeah that's nice that
you're a fossil
the sediment layer okay how are you I'm
I'm tired today's the first day where I
don't feel as tired this dog is is the
death of me why don't you bring the dog
um well she's not fully vacced yet even
though your dogs are probably not really
going out too much are they they're
fully vacs I know but um if they go out
to the dog park let's say and they like
they don't go step on something that has
parvo on it oh no and and trace it back
it's like contact the contact they could
we haven't been in the dog park in a
minute yeah I've never done anything
weird with my also the real reason why I
don't bring her here is because she's a
[__] demon she Barks A lot
she got Chow Chow in her and Tibetan
Mastiff
and unfortunately not a lot of Saint
Bernard apparently because Saint
Bernards are like very compliant uh
submissive
and and uh you know very good like
service animals whereas the other two
breeds are awful so she is incredibly
smart but also incredibly stubborn she's
an escape artist she is very loud very
Barky
love she will bark for hours without
getting tired that's hard that is really
annoying yeah believer don't bring her
here
oh
okay I mean I will inevitably bring her
here when you know we want her okay yeah
and she's still doing it sometimes has
the capacity to pee and poo in places
well not poo but pee Shredder and
Alfredo do that all the time first of
all they had don't any and recently yeah
you're right they've gotten a lot better
about it but
oh I'm I'm potty training the absolute
living [__] out of her but like by the
way it's still hard there's only one
bathroom in operation you might notice
the one on the left the doors busted why
what happened you break it
um Olivia got locked in the bathroom and
Abe had to slam it down not exactly
whatever yeah yeah that's that's what
happened Dan she was screaming I don't
know I don't remember by the way this
Thursday uh Marvel teddy bear thanks
no next Thursday
God damn right yeah June 8th next
Thursday yeah it's gonna be awesome it's
gonna be sick dude
in the Marvel Universe we are part of
the Marvel Universe now
I don't have it pulled up oh you want me
to open it yeah here's what happened to
the door yeah I used the right one okay
Ethan saves Olivia I came down here you
think your screen's not working
are you not able to see that
okay for now let's just do it on mine
and then I'll go fix it
perfect
we're trying to remember
you look like kind of a bad [__]
and the hair's looking good and you were
you're wearing that slimming ass black
tea always
one
oh my God
okay I wish I was there I love doing I
love breaking stuff but we have one
other door two one you want to see how
well they're coming to fix it I'd be
down let's see how long it takes you to
break it she wanted to do that yeah yeah
let's set it up wow we only have one
bathroom right but the cam says if you
do the lock it'll says if it's occupied
there's no way that deadbolt was in them
like that it says occupied dude who's
opening a door that says occupied that's
insane then go downstairs there's two
working bathrooms downstairs Dan why
don't we go break there yeah break one
of those no no we're breaking it
God damn you have no workers rights
claims you have two bathrooms downstairs
and one bathroom next door with it dude
because the second door I broke well
because it wouldn't be good if we had no
operating bathrooms I wanna I wanna I
wonder if I get one tap it there's no
way there's no way I could one tap it
you might be able to I'm actually I'd
love to know because the door is
surprisingly heavy I think I think
shoulder checking it is probably the way
to go but I want to kick it like cool
style you know what I mean SWAT team
[__] I'm I'm curious to see I like that
you guys didn't shoulder check it and
instead try to kick it I shoulder
checked it yeah yeah that's what I'm
saying like that's how you're supposed
I've broken doors before if yeah I got
it in three hits so I think you
definitely could get it in one
one hit that'll be interesting to see I
I'd love can you see it
okay
so uh we'll set that up for you
okay at least it's only 150 to fix it
it's like well worth the entertainment
oh yeah yeah but how long
next week I think they said they'll be
here oh I don't want you don't want both
of your bathrooms
that's crazy he wants to walk downstairs
they walk down 30 seconds trust me the
people want to see you break the door
and I'm one of those people okay like
people are going to be pissed at Dad if
we don't do this
because you're like oh I don't want to
poop with a [__] without I like I stand
with Dan I'm very either I like that
you're the one who uses it most
frequently and for the longest duration
and you're the one who also doesn't care
so there you go which is weird be like
Ethan
there is a first of all there is a
locking mechanism although it doesn't
work it says occupied
you see the lights on you see this is
occupied let's do the math people
okay
you know
we can do a pull and then it's not up to
me it's up to the people that's insane I
do know what they're gonna say
yeah so uh what else is going on
uh we got some good topics today
obviously target has been uh at the
center
of
conservative media scorn
yeah finally dude finally I'm sick and
tired of it
finally someone is speaking out against
uh you know Binkies with rainbows on
them yeah so so bad
yeah I want I saw a shirt with a rainbow
on it for like you're gay now and I
actually I I immediately went home and
uh started looking at gay gay porn yeah
I went on Grindr and I actually I
actually cheated on Ela with the dude
it's all Targets fault yeah okay that's
literally what you're describing is like
not far off from what Benny Johnson does
on a regular basis damn it Target you
made me wanna [__] a dude yeah Benny
Johnson we know what you do we know what
you do when you go on work trip he is
gay right Benny Johnson I mean he's not
out oh he's not I thought he was open no
he's not he's not openly a homosexual
straight out no he has a wife who Benny
has a wife who no longer allows him to
go on business trips by himself wait
wait wait I thought he was oh no I I
wonder why Benny Johnson an adult man is
not allowed to travel on his phone how
do you know that
I'm a journalist by the way Benny
Johnson for those who don't know is the
the left can't meme guy yeah he is the
he is the the left Camp meme guy Vinnie
Johnson famously got fired from BuzzFeed
for plagiarizing which is like really
funny because how do you plagiarize a
listicle like what the [__] it's already
like bottom of the barrel writing
um but he got fired from Buzzy for
Blazers and got far from another place
for also plagiarizing again
um he is one of the grossest little
freaks
on the planet we need a support group
for his wife and Crowder's ex yeah
um it doesn't work for me either we have
a Benny video
um related to the Target thing I swear
so I was under the pretense and I'm not
even saying this to be joke
I 100 thought he was Uncle out and about
gay I mean he's zesty he's a zesty
fellow that's what happens when you
that's I mean listen if you every time
you go on a business trip every time you
go on a business trip you're sucking at
least like three dicks like you know
yeah just come out at that point I want
to know about these business trips tell
me more I mean you know uh when you're a
political operative you travel around
the country to go to I guess various
different targets
is that where it goes down me and Target
I don't know if he's doing it in the
Target bathroom [__] parking lot baby
2 A.M 2 p.m 2 A.M all right so here is
uh Benny Johnson Target is in total
Retreat a whistleblower sent me an
exclusive internal exclusive
internal Target memo ordering the
deconstruction of the groomer Pride
section
I went to Target we reported from last
week to check I was shocked at what we
found I love this they panic I love that
they're doing like you know
investigative reporting on [__]
Target uh Pride sections like what are
you doing they go this is the power we
have to protect our children what about
the
30 to 50 percent of trans kids that
attempt suicide that seems like a
greater risk to our children no they
want that they're demons yeah okay so
here's Benny who is not gay apparently
he's definitely gay according to him
Ground Zero of the boycott Target
campaigning whistleblower from inside of
target has actually given us he's in
Target parking lot like they just need
to set up like a reporting Booth outside
bro's acting like he's in the karengal
valley dude he's like oh my God I'm in a
forward operating base we're under live
fire right now right he should be in
full camo and body it's like bro you are
literally passing for uh by a row of
Nissan Altimas on your way to the
[__] most like Suburban housewife ass
uh shopping store you could go to Target
is my safe place
I like Target I like I like shopping I
like Walmart I you know
yeah I'm a fan of of that sort of [__]
the The Whistleblower was actually the
um cashier as he was checking out
he's got an exclusive there yeah
corporate directives as it pertains to
the pride display this year these
corporate directives say that they need
to remove a huge portion of the items
permanently and they're gonna get oh
thank God oh no wait look away look away
by the way this dress is fire for a kid
they love rainbows my my son Theodore
rainbow is his favorite thing if you ask
him it's already over it's over you say
what's your favorite color he says my
favorite color is Rainbow okay
absolutely greedy okay yeah what the
[__] Theodore's like oh I like all of
them oh okay sick yeah okay yeah good
luck explaining that to him
but this dress is kind of fire like my
son would like this color scheme
so what's happening uh the pride section
inside of the children's Department
effectively at Target is any of this
real is it actually happening is any of
this real
we're going to our Target the same
Target that we went through actually
last week to show you this
what's up wow
guys this is he's so excited God I want
I just I hate him so much because like
he is such a pathetic [__] loser okay
what makes me angry isn't like the
bigotry or whatever I don't give a [__]
okay I don't care there are infinitely
more bigoted people out there that are
doing like infinitely worse uh acts of
bigotry right what frustrates me about
this is how [__] He's oozing with
this like pathetic Aura where he's
excited that he got big old Target to do
his bidding like oh we got something
done guys like he's like nothing changed
okay nothing changed it is kind of
somewhat pathetic that Target actually
bowed it absolutely is it absolutely is
but of course they bout it's it's
[__] pandering they were pandering
they were never like actually invested
in uh you know defending gay people or
anything like that
um also Tim pool and everyone else is so
[__] stupid there are seasonal or
there are quarterly earning reports and
other Market forces that contribute to
like targets uh stock price falling yeah
okay which usually tracks with the rest
of the uh you know uh large what are
they called like big box stores I don't
know these kinds of these kinds of like
uh retail uh stores in general
um and yet they like point to uh they
point to like a five percent drop uh in
like five days and they're like we did
it we we own this multinational
corporation it's like
you're such a [__] idiot man there is
no shot that a meaningful amount of
people stopped shopping there you know
why because where the [__] else you
gonna go in most places Target's the
only place where you can go buy a wooden
spoon and a bouncy ball and also a bidet
and also a condolences car because your
grandma died where else can you do all
those things in one place I also love
like I'm also always shopping for the
bouncy ball right after my grandma died
well you gotta I need to be happy I need
to I need to be happy again it's been a
tough week
which was also a river
her genital region was exposed dimly it
had the appearance of a thick mat of
hair she was stroking herself
absent-mindedly
she walked over to me with a handful of
pubic hair compacted into something
resembling a large artist's paintbrush
Jordan and pushed this at my face
I raised my arm several times to deflect
her hand
finally unwilling to hurt her or
interfere with her any further I let her
have her way hey you know what
at least it's not a gay relationship at
least it was his grandma not his grandpa
you know what I mean so it's I think
that's that clears that's actually a
fair point
Walmart see yeah where are they gonna go
Walmart pride and joy over at Walmart so
that's actually my favorite uh idiotic
thing that conservatives have been doing
is like it basically shows that this
outrage is completely manufactured and
also that like it's not built on solid
principles or fundamentals like news
flash oh shocker conservatives are angry
at something [__] right because like
when they did this with Bud Light
Dylan Mulvaney's face appeared on a
singular can of Bud Light it was a
one-off Instagram story uh Bud Light was
trying to tap into the queer Market uh
through Dylan Mulvaney it became a
national news story and everybody got
mad at Bud Light and you know
Republicans are like oh I'm shooting my
Bud Light like I will never drink Bud
Light before [__] myself and ever
again frisky today yeah so they did all
of that except like they were like yeah
we're gonna do Yingling which is owned
by a trump supporter it's a Pennsylvania
brand it's like a very old American
Brewery right and it's owned by a family
uh and the main guy is a trump supporter
except Yingling has of course just like
Bud Light just like Coors just like all
of the a b inbev products have also uh
sponsored the Philadelphia Pride Parade
because of course they do that every
single Corporation does it but no one's
angry at Yingling you want to know why
because
they would have to come to the
recognition that every single brand does
this [__] because they want gay people
to drink their product that's it it's
just pandering so that you know people
with disposable income from different
demographics will go and buy their [__]
that's it
um well I think they're it's a demonic
conspiracy to turn kids into a
sacrificial uh it's just like all these
conservatives have gay ass children
that's what it is and then they're like
oh my God my child turned gay because he
saw a [__] a binky with a rainbow on
it it's like no man your kid's just gay
it's fine like there's no that's a big
game man yeah so um there's been a whole
Saga you know
uh let's see here yeah it starts with my
boy who we've talked about before Ethan
Schmidt this guy's a revolutionary man
that dude's a Nazi oh yeah no but he's
the best and brightest he uh he was on
the the Vanguard of this
um
and He's a brave Soldier let me show we
watched a video of him
and uh
uh Barnes and Noble
where's the Ethan Schmidt clip guy oh
here it is another another thing while
you're pulling that up another thing
that is like obviously uh yet another
indication that this is all manufactured
uh drama from like people who are
looking for uh you know busy work
they're like bored they're isolated
they're alienated they want a sense of
community they see this kind of thing
and they go all right this is a place
where we can like get together and like
release all of our frustrations of
living in this capitalist dystopia it's
ironic because like you're exercising uh
this this right to protest against a
brand that is doing something for
marketing purposes like it's not this is
not policy this is not legislation
you're just doing the exact same [__]
that all of these supposedly
quote-unquote hysterical sjws did in
like the Obama era in the end of the
Obama era and in 2016 where they were
like uh freak the [__] out over a TV
show and like try to get a person
recasted on a TV show or whatever and
then the brand would capitulate and go
all right [__] it we're gonna do that
like that is not material change it's
just like
nearsighted it is it's it's basically it
is you're not changing anything
dramatically nothing actually improved
in your life in your immediate life and
you certainly did not tackle any of the
structural forms of Oppression gayness
or even the structural forms of
repression that you are advocating for
if you're a conservative you didn't do
anything you didn't do anything at all
okay you just made a brand react to you
crying like a whiny little [__] I was
reading a really interesting story
and this is why I get upset when Abba
and preach and these kinds are Dumb and
Dumber do you like that one better
no you got to come up with you Babble
and read you'll find one I believe you I
believe you'll find one Babble and reach
anyway so the reason that I get angry
when they're like oh we were just
talking about trans people in sports
what are you talking about
um
is that they're so the whole Genesis of
this trans people and sports thing
traces back to
um Christian
political groups that were looking for a
way to turn trans people into like a
political uh topic I'm laughing because
the New York Times Daily covered it uh
this morning and it was very good it was
actually one of the surprisingly good
New York Times Daily Michael Barbara
moments right well yeah you're right so
he says
um why is that funny
I was just I was just listening to it on
the way over here that's why I'm smiling
um what's funny about that
what yeah so why are you getting mad so
[__] so
um
apparently
they they were trying to hit the Tran
stuff
uh and it just wasn't resonating like
they were talking about how they were
trying to like ban uh trans people going
to different bathrooms yes and there was
this huge pushback Brands were uh
boycotting and North Carolina North
Carolina the North Carolina bathroom
bills were absolutely fought hard
against by corporations and politicians
alike there was a lot of signal boosting
around that everybody recognized that it
was a dumb issue so they went back to
the [__] drawing board and they found
a new Focus tested focus group tested uh
issue surrounding the trans issue
because after the transports they found
it and once they figured out that that
resonated with people because of their
sense of like fairness I guess yeah and
then they frame they started to frame it
like this is a big issue happening in
the country when clearly it's like ew
why what the [__] to do yeah here's the
problem okay here's the hold on hold on
they say can any blue check Christian
tell me why this is okay and pride isn't
[__] this is like repulsive like what is
that no that's they're saying that like
that's gross it is I I this is actually
a common that's a hasanabe tactic for
those of you who are watching at home if
you ever got one of these [__]
who's like oh yeah like they're
sexualizing our children because that
that Binky looks hot or whatever the
[__] these creepy pervers are saying
dude what do you think about child
pageants anyone that attends this needs
to be on an FBI watch list I'm not even
[__] kidding this this I'm like wow
that that's yeah child beauty pageants
are [__] disgusting they're gross
they are certainly not good for the
psyche of the children they're not good
for the parents they're not good for
anybody they're only good for the select
few judges who probably can't be near a
school for you know legal reasons um
that's the only people that enjoy the
child beauty pageants I think so anyway
it was cooked up basically in a lab by a
bunch of uh uh Christian bigots who are
looking for another Fringe a wedge issue
and also just to [__] on anybody who's
LGBT and they found like you said Focus
tested on this trans and sports thing
and that's how they kind of opened up
this topic and made it this whole now
it's like the sole focus of the
conservative movement and somehow
everything's about trans people
um and and so when I hear people be like
oh Trans people in sports
it's like you you're
you're just doing you're doing exactly
what they want you to do yeah because
you just you get them you're used to you
are a you are an idiot you are being
played a fool you have been conditioned
into getting upset about this thing it's
not a thing it's not even a real thing
yeah it's not even a real [__] thing
there's like three trans people in like
every [__] State there's like three
trans miners participating in like high
school swim meets and in every state
maximum right and yet uh you know people
make a big stink about it and this is
like taking up so much time in space
when people are suffering there's no
[__] Health Care there's no social
security uh there's no safety nets and
and the conservative movement has they
have no policy they're playing you
they're playing you uh and and you are a
uh
a tool and a tool well there's a word
for it I'm forgetting a patsy a lemming
a [__] a mark but that's not hard
you're a loser you're unwillingly uh not
right talking about you ABBA if you
didn't know and and it opens up the door
perfectly to like broader transistors
for a lot of people it basically gives
people like uh like put in it gives
people a foot in and it gives people the
opportunity to say like transphobic [__]
um because the ultimate goal when you
actually talk to people who are like oh
Trans people trans girls uh should not
compete with CIS girls or whatever when
you actually talk to them and you like
walk them through the steps of like what
should be done then
once you're once you have addressed the
ethics or the fairness in sports uh side
of the conversation which you know
that's equality of outcome seems a
little bit like that to me
um which I don't like Anyway Sports
they're not supposed to be [__] Fair
it's supposed to be unfair
um
you still have more resources and money
get to train with better stuff yeah
of course even that part is not like a
full meritocracy or Michael Phelps has
like a genetic Advantage LeBron James
has a genetic Advantage like you know
you don't want to stop those people and
if you're if you're considering that
like uh oh well they're taking
um their genetic advantages they they
have uh the the male uh physiology uh
and and are like developing a male body
structure before uh they are
transitioning then
um okay that's an advantage certainly I
just don't consider that to be like
I'm not cynical enough to assume that
that is like an unfair Advantage due to
uh some some secret underlying uh
cynical reason like they're doing this
because they want to win the [__]
high school swim meet they really think
like you're starting to free to get an
edge on Sports but people used to say
that about gay people all the time they
were like oh you're just gay for
attention for like they would always say
like oh you're you're gay for attention
you're gay for attention you're doing
this because you want attention you're
doing this because you want benefits
what are the societal benefits of coming
out as a gay man I don't know
suicide but but like they would say that
right and my answer always was my answer
always was this okay suck a dick then if
you if it's for if it's just like that
easy then then put a dick in your ass
suck a dick put a dick in your ass have
fun you know if that if it's if that's
all it takes if that's like what people
are doing it for then then try it out
well okay thank you for the permission
and uh but the same goes for for like
trans people right you know what I mean
if it's for if it's for a competitive
Advantage who the [__] is going to
undertake HRT you know like psych
evaluations for years before there are
interesting protocols for it though like
if you have transitioned uh into a male
if you've been on hormones for a certain
period of time it should theoretically
eliminate the majority of whatever
Advantage you had
um
so that's interesting but the thing
about the trans people in sport it's
just not happening
there's not like a a just whole roster
of trans men who are just dominating
Sports just not happening anywhere
but anyway okay so uh I just thought it
was really interesting how they
engineered that topic and then all these
uh morons like ab and preach are just
feeding in they're opening the door to
transphobia and they love it also they
made 30 did you see the compilation we
made oh no not the timer what is this
did you did you watch the compilation I
made were they no they tranced 140 times
no I did not I did not watch it
why is there a con why is there a timer
on because I'm not allowed to talk about
them we have to put them on a timeline
oh thank God okay I'm on an embargo um
actually
just want to say we are now fully set up
to kick in a [__] door I think if
y'all want oh you want to do it live I
mean yeah but we did last time oh okay
what do you think you want to do it now
that's why people were saying door in
the chat yeah we do it live okay I'll
try it I'll do it live we can't even
edit it now I feel entitled to show
Hassan
that compilation
you feel entitled to do yeah I made it I
made it for him maybe you watched it I
sent it to you the the the one where
there's like saying trans and there's a
there's a number I have seen that one
the one that we made yeah I'm not
surprised I I brought you set up I
brought that up before like where when I
was looking I I needed to do a I needed
to do a cursory analysis on whether they
were you know what kind of opinion they
had about trans people all right all
right here we go we're going we're going
to the door
give us some music thank you
meet you in the bathroom okay
and get some more systems over here okay
this one or no this one that's the one
we broke
so Libby's gonna Close the Door full
full full latch okay you want to feel
the doors right yeah it's pretty solid
door too
okay okay the problem here is that
there's not a lot of space to like
to to brace yourself to like do a
[__] kick we've all been operating
under the same condition yes no no I
know I'm saying I'm I'm getting my
bearings in I'm not gonna be able to
kick this with a with a kick I don't
think let's see I think you might oh my
God
wait hold on I think our building's
about to collapse what the [__] should
happen
I think our I don't know if our beams
can support them [__]
I love the karate
partner one kicking what no it's fine
yeah I don't think I'll be able to take
it all right so now we're going to the
shoulder
whoa hello
it's hard you know what I think is
happening Evie was hitting it lower were
the hinges yeah that could have helped
but Amy's a psycho man you should have
seen the way he threw himself at that
door yeah
Freedom are you okay Olivia
oh my God
thank you do you want to keep it that's
a that's a Keepsake for you
here let's look at the damage bring it
in here oh
yeah this this yeah there it is you know
what I mean I shouldn't have gone so
high I think exactly Amy was hitting at
lower yeah but I gotta say
Avis he's holding up no for sure he that
man did work on that door
Shredder so scared
oh my God
but I don't think I was able to I don't
I was like
maybe if there was more space between
the wall and the door yeah
what happened this mirror almost fell
over and put it I'm gonna turn the
camera
boxes have a
there it is
two broken doors
history podcasts
back up Jeremiah was literally joking
today that he didn't want to fix another
door and I said well Hassan's coming in
so we might have to
when we fix it I love breaking stuff
it's so much fun when we fix it we
should break them again
stop all right I'm kidding we've done
enough Amy how are you feeling after
Hassan's I gotta say he didn't necess he
didn't really outperform you I did not I
think it was just technique
is all in the technique just take the
dub man
he's being humble I had the dub you
wanted to run this experiment again I
had it I was a hero you still are bro
that's why you take it from me how did I
take it from you AB said yesterday that
what allowed him to do it it was all
mentality it wasn't actually technique
it was that he imagined that child in
that burning car and he manifested an
inner strength that he didn't know was
there before baby I'm trying to give you
props you had you you entered that door
with the same Gusto as Hassan who's 6'4
and much heavier and he's wearing darks
or whatever those things are well that
doesn't you know that counts look at
those I was trying to do it with my
Birkenstocks
you know what I mean now I'm trying to
give you props baby oh thank you damn
okay when I try to compliment you you
don't accept it you go oh Ethan just
insults me all the time here I'm trying
to build you up and you go no
it's incredible I can't win with you
it's incredible how um
how thirsty breaking down a door mix
people because yesterday people were
going absolutely feral over a b doing
that right and now I'm looking at the
chat and my God honestly I just
rewatched the tape I watched the footage
yeah you're right I should have just
gone early and I should have gone low
that was good do you you helped me yeah
you're welcome you helped me with that
if you want to move again when we get
the doors fixed if you want to go again
I don't think I'll be able to one tap it
though it is it's a deadbolt so it's
definitely a lot stronger than the door
is surprisingly strong it's yeah I mean
if it wasn't a deadbolt if it's like one
of those uh regular
like I've broken many doors before
usually if it's like one of those
regular locks that you can card into
yeah those break much easier
obviously the the uh the material that
the door is made of is significant as
well but especially when it's a deadbolt
it makes it much more difficult to break
yeah well good job well done well done
I'm glad we did it yeah I did it we are
bathroom we have no doors in our
bathroom I gotta say though you know
that makes me feel secure when I'm in
there [__] that I'm well no one's
getting him no Intruders oh yeah
let me in there
so anyway here's Ethan Schmidt who um is
a darling of the right
this guy's the best and brightest
satanic Pride propaganda I prefer yeah
well she's the she's my queen yeah she's
awesome you support Satan
what's God gonna think of that I don't
believe in God
oh he goes what now
he went wow wow what now [__] wow his
dialogue tree was very short he didn't
he didn't have anything to say to that
he yeah he was not expecting someone to
just come up and be like yeah I love
Satan and I don't believe in God I don't
have a I don't have a response to my
dialogue tree
support the propaganda that's targeting
against
it's all of our kids TV shows
it's all over they're targeting the kids
choose to wear whatever they want
do you support the sexualization of kids
through Pride property do you understand
that she's not making the clothes or the
decisions on behalf of this company she
could I think she should be the CEO of
Target I'm in favor wait the way that
she dealt with this [__] Gremlin is
like textbook I love her I love her she
is my hero I watched the video a while
back because this is not even from like
the recent Pride stuff this is like old
oh it is yeah this happened like a
couple months back you're right he he
really his [__] goober was like
literally a trendsetter yeah the dumbest
person maybe of all time I I I really
looked around because when like they
they announced that they were pulling
the products uh I want to say two weeks
ago now and when I was looking around
for videos of the supposed harassment
every article written about the
situation was just referring to his
videos he did this I I really think like
Target changed their National like
obviously it became a thing no no this
is before this is way before the pride
stuff I remember watching this video
months ago oh but he I genuinely believe
he put up the prices really early too he
did this yeah it could have been it
could have been like put up like Pride
displays could have been put up like two
months prior or something but I'm fairly
certain this is like at least two months
old but I would say that he did this two
months yeah he was at the first Vanguard
there's a old video from 2007 of like
this mentally unstable lady looking at
Like A Rainbow in the sprinklers and
going it's the medals that are like you
know uh that are making our kids one day
now that's a famous classic bit right
people have resurfaced it they think
it's like Roseanne Barr it's not
um you know they're they're showing it
all over it's going viral on Tick Tock
again yeah why am I bringing this up why
are you because yesterday's
schizophrenic takes are today raise
conservative policies okay the more
insane you are the more unhinged you are
the more you are going to the be the the
leader of the Vanguard and the
conservative Movement Like that's why
Ethan Schmidt doing this like weird
creepy perverted harassment campaign is
now seen as like almost uh pioneering
did you make this cam
hmm yeah oh my god well cam doesn't need
to Photoshop another [__] Flag where
Donald Trump has the LG lgbts for Trump
uh flag that he like was waving in 2016.
we love the gays
um everybody this needs to be every
response under Benny Johnson's tweets
do you understand spend the time cam if
you can to make this look perfect
because I know you just cooked it up
this one is real that one's not fake
listen spend the time to make that
perfect cam sure on it and then we need
Benny Johnson to see this under every
tweet he makes
I mean he sees it when he goes into
every gay bar anyways and he's very um
so he will absolutely uh this is
fantastic I love this for him and his
family he's definitely going to see it
when he when he logs on the grinder
during pride month and he's like oh no
grinder has gone woke they went they
made grinder whoa yeah uh there's a
comment here though it says the lady
actually said she was severely harassed
now to go to therapy and she has PD uh
PTSD so I love her she's a Legend So
anyway let's watch
is something that we can help you with
just asking people questions what about
you sir do you support this any
questions
but here to cause any disturbance I'm
just asking questions
I am the undercover the loss prevention
wait hold on I'll be like wait what the
[__] they have undercover yeah no no of
course of course playing clothes police
cruising around Target no it's not he's
not a cop he's undercover loss
prevention so he like walks around
probably literally
you know snoops around or black people
in the store let's be [__] real
that's like his job
that'd be crazy some random dudes just
following you
but without [__] uh you know making
it obvious
so uh yeah oh okay so I'm just asking
questions so do you support the satanic
propaganda I'm not sure questions
what you need to do is you either need
to leave the store
God will judge you guys okay I mean I
can't please
and also is that Archer yeah look what a
dork he is yeah so there's a couple
things that I want to mention here other
than like the actual video itself uh or
like the you know this [__] goober
and his reaction or uh the wonderful
Brave uh LGBT Defender uh who happens to
work at Target
um
it's the normies that are walking around
okay because he like
regularly used to do this and he would
like always go up to normally be like do
do you think this is all right and most
people are like yeah
like what of it like yeah it is judged
because like the Normie reaction is that
they don't give a [__] it's so stupid
you have to be like literally you have
to be an insane person to look at
rainbows on a T-shirt and go this is
ungodly and we need to put an end to
this people are asking did we watch this
last week no he did this he does the
same shtick he did it in Barnes Noble he
famously did that I think it was him who
like tried to break the one the the
pride display as well and like gently
Landed It on the Ground
and no took baby steps on it
so Target says they're pulling Pride
related items for safety of employees
which is great they're they're like yeah
they were basically being uh terrorized
and threatened with violence
which uh is apparently not something
that the conservatives do
ever
yeah he was um he also got served um
a restraining order from and he's not
allowed to be inside of any Target
yeah that's awesome
um but his background is full of
wonderful goody uh you know conservative
goodness
uh they're they're putting in the chat
but the far right troll was convicted of
both trespassing and Scottsdale and an
extreme DUI an extreme DUI what is
Extreme DUI does that mean he went off a
ramp and like launched 20 feet I don't
[__] know it was extreme yeah he it
was extreme I was doing X Games with it
drive angry
um in Chandler in 2021 he also has been
arrested for violating his probation and
failing to appear in court as recently
as June 2022 according to court records
but like getting a DUI is basically like
a rite of passage for being a
conservative freak so hey you know what
he's on he's on his way to become a
Florida Congress person
God's Gonna judge me uh Ethan but uh the
judge is gonna judge you to prison right
thank you everybody here's Matt Walsh
who always has the best
pride month kicked off a few weeks early
by unveiling their ever-expanding
selection of LGBT themed merchandise
with much of it specifically aimed at
children the daily wire reports quote
Target unveiled a number of clothing
items and accessories including apparel
and books meant for babies and young
children
latest Pride collection in addition to
the adult collection which included a
t-shirt emblazoned with the words queer
queer queer queer a short sleeve bright
green boiler suit and a hoodie which
declares not a phase the company offered
several items meant for kids and babies
the store is selling ozzies and small
shirts with friends pause it pause it
proud and just
you have to we have to mention here that
like one conservatives well oh I wasn't
even gonna get into that but that that
was you know we can get into that in a
second conservatives are such [__]
freaks as you all know and they sell the
ugliest dumbest [__] like the dumbest
merchandise on the [__] planet one of
my favorite things one of my favorite
pastimes to look at like ugly Facebook
shirts that conservatives sell on their
stories if you look at like their kid
stuff if you look at their kid product
where are you going
if you look at their kid product
half the time
they're [__] kid products are are
like the dumbest [__] on the planet like
they got guns on them you know Second
Amendment baby that kind of thing but
also did you say about Maps
oh no oh no it's so it's on Matt Walsh
himself as a child's book he made a
transphobic children's book it's so
obvious what they're doing is so
transparent the grift is that they now
have an alternative to every single
thing that like Target is trying to sell
and they're just selling dumbasses a fat
markup for the crime of being an
absolute baboon-brained idiotic
conservative it's like the pink tax but
you can absolutely Escape it in this
regard but it's it's the conservative
pink tax the dumb tax Matt Walsh who is
very concerned about what Target is
marketing to children
has put himself naked
in a diaper
uh and he's selling this on
dailywire.com that show The Leftovers
it's called a great show by the way it's
called the sweet baby
and um it's because he calls this is the
sweet baby gang his fans call themselves
The Sweet Baby gang I I repeat alert
alert Matt Walsh's fandom calls
themselves the sweet baby gang there are
videos of this sweet baby gang like
talking to Matt Walsh on Tick Tock
asking Matt Walsh to come to their
wedding talking about how Mount Walsh
was very informative and very important
in their lives and in their development
to you know they really beefed up their
their transphobia and their transphobic
perspectives I'm not kidding these are
some of the most divorced dads of all
time
this is [__] this doll is like this is
demonic I mean you won't talk about
Satan baby once but you know this is
literally worse than uh when you when
you did the gotcha on Ali London like
this is literally but but of course hey
guys that's Mount Walsh she's a straight
guy so it doesn't matter you can be he's
gonna throw here he can be as weird as
possible like ultimately
I'll say this
I'm not gonna [__] sit here and act
like Mount Walsh it's it's whatever it's
a gimmick it's weird but I wouldn't like
you know run a crusade over it okay I
think what Matt Walsh says is
significantly worse than this [__]
baby product that they're Shilling but
make no mistake if any
any trans content creator made something
similar to this Matt Walsh would
literally tell his audience to purchase
the AR-15 and go shoot them in the
[__] head yep okay
um ridiculous so anyway shout out to
Target
um yes Target would not sell that by the
way hell no who would God no no no
retailer would sell that period uh this
is an interesting story that I saw this
morning Jeremy uh boring is that his
last name
what a loser it is what a [__] idiot
this is the co-owner of the daily wire
Jeremy boring yeah well he's the
co-owner he's the he is the co-owner
he's the co-founder and co-ceo alongside
Ben shibibo
um this guy's a real [__] goober so
anyway he details a really interesting
story
where they had this deal with Twitter
Elon musk's Twitter
to Premiere what is a women which is um
Matt Walsh's transphobic uh document
quote unquote documentary and uh upon
reviewing it Elon Musk Twitter said
not only can we not play this
documentary
it would be severely restricted
of in the algorithm for views because of
hateful conduct
which is funny because if you watch the
documentary it's most certainly just
pure hateful conduct yeah but this is
Elon Musk they're darling well I can I
just say something about but so they're
turning on him they're turning on Elon
they're not Elon will do everything in
his power to be like no now everyone has
to like literally watch Matt Walsh
before they log on to Twitter oh my God
I'm so sorry I don't know interesting
about Elon Musk
is that for every single pride month
every single year since 2018 Elon Musk
has always said if you don't like gay
people don't buy my [__] cars this
year is the first year where he hasn't
really said anything I am very
interested to see what Tesla does about
this because Tesla is obviously woke and
soy and gay they're an electric vehicle
and if you care about the environment
you're gay everybody knows that right
um so
Elon Musk there are tweets of this if
you want to go find it Elon Musk is
every single year literally not only
done the whole like gay pride Tesla [__]
you know Tesla the rainbow colors but
also has said if you don't like that
like if you have a problem with uh Tesla
being woke or being open-minded to
people from all different kinds of
backgrounds then you can [__] right off
pride is not a virtue I mean no Tesla
used to do their logo and the pride
colors and the rainbow flag like every
year Tim Poole is coping about this
story he says I'm assuming
at Elon Musk just wasn't yet made aware
of what's going on but if the showing of
what a woman is not restored Tim Casp
will terminate it's Enterprise blue
subscription
not the blue and and what's next is cat
turd gonna [__] stop making fart
jokes and poop jokes oh no no dude no
Elon that's only like one of 10 people
that paid for that [__] you better
[__] listen dude dude dude that's
[__] up man that's [__] up Tim being
absolutely woke of you dog
boycott
so has Elon uh
I want to know the mentality of like
there's gotta be one
is this true Elon Musk there's got to be
one guy like this out there Ethan who
like still thinks Tim Poole is like a
Centrist I want to know what that guy's
life is like I think it's Tim Poole is
the only one that believes that yeah
someone's like yeah I I'm watching my
favorite liberal commentator Tim Poole
absolutely so I do wonder if Elon is
going to comment on this he's ignoring
it for now
uh uh well he's actually uh I just
looked it up and apparently he's doing a
big hoopla in China today bro he orders
this time which they probably won't love
either so
yeah that's always a that's always a
funny ass moment where like you realize
that Elon Musk is one straight up a dog
wait he did respond he said this was a
mistake by many people at Twitter it is
definitely allowed
whether or not you agree with using
someone's preferred pronouns not doing
so is at most rude and certainly breaks
no law nobody claimed it did yeah it's
not illegal this is the worst way to go
about this like not illegal it's not
illegal to call someone the n-word
either I mean
you know well he allows that yeah yeah
I'm just saying I don't understand that
but he says I should note that I do
personally use someone's preferred
pronouns oh [__] I'm canceling my Blues
dude what the [__] someone's preferred
name simply from the standpoint of good
manners however for the same reason I
object to Rude Behavior ostracism or
threats of violence oh thank God wrong
pronoun or name thank God he said that
for a second I thought he was like
pro-trans oh my God he's oh thank God
all right so dude basically isn't going
to satisfy anyone though how are you
going to fix this no that answer will
satisfy elon's dick riders the dick
writers yeah but like Jeremy boring he's
not gonna like that listen to the the
deal they had they said we decided to
give the documentary for free for 24
hours they said Twitter responded with
the enthusiasm and offered us the
opportunity to buy a package to host the
movie on a dedicated event page and to
promote it to everyone on Twitter for
the first 10 hours can you imagine this
is like this is like uh comparable of
like
promoting like Earth
yeah this is literally Elon Musk being
like Oh Birth of a Nation is so sick we
should show this to everyone by force if
Elon showed this documentary to
everybody it would be I think there
would be hell to pay I mean it is really
just a disgusting hateful [__]
documentary hosted by the one of the
dumbest people alive yeah no it's like
it it's it's one of those things where
if you have a child or if you've ever
interacted with a kid one thing that
kids always do is ask why right they
always ask you why and like take you
down step by step like why why is this
happening why is my response to myself
when he does that what I go why and he
goes why and I go why and he goes why
and we go why why why why why okay what
that's how I get them but usually if you
ask like you know why is this happening
and then you describe it and then they
ask why again like it's a never-ending
cycle until you have no answers for it
and that's basically what Matt Walsh
turned into a documentary where he's
like what is a woman why why what is a
woman why and it's like you can reduce
everything you can do that about
literally any concept on the [__]
planet but of course if your entire
audience are a bunch of mouth-breathing
Geeks that are looking for any and every
opportunity to be like yeah I knew it
trans people are [__] crazy and
they're weird and they're wrong oh thank
God they look at that and go this is
brilliant this is cinema this is you
know I love this it's the best thing
I've ever seen yeah I mean it is
actually getting sweet baby
from conservatives crazy here let's
check out their merch let's go Brandon
that's what you're selling Father's Day
gift box
to if you hate your dad huh
uh do not comply let's go Brandon Jesus
Christ the mouthwash collection
uh a candle what what are you guys
selling what is a candle who's buying
that
you can't be serious [__] losers man
losers why are they selling candles this
is like who's buying left handle wire
leftist tears that doesn't you can't
burn liquid we need wax it's just like
it's hello the science doesn't add up
look it's merchandise for a very
specific type of goober
okay Big Mike yeah that's what I'm
talking about
I wonder how many people bought that can
zero I want to know I want to know again
the mentality of the person who buys the
Michael Knowles candle this is psychotic
what is that a truth bomb hold on let me
see the video there's a seven minute
video to sell this thing
why are you doing promo over these
[__] ironically going to start
buying this nobody's buying this [__] I
promise
what the [__] is it
how big is it
well it's 200 bucks so I'm assuming
it's probably not that big
it doesn't what is it an ornamental
thing is that what it is
no I'm about to drop on you but dude
bomb them uh the explosives are sold
separately unfortunately uh
you'll have to pick those up from your
local proud boys chapter
but uh it is it is easily modded to be
converted into a real bomb thank God
yeah bomb them again let's see what else
we got
um Greg gutfield everybody loves the gut
yeah my favorite my favorite and also
most part the king of late night
yeah he he is the king of late night so
check this what kind of what kind of
great takes does the king of late night
have this is like when I saw this video
I was like what year is it I sure hope
he doesn't say something weird about
pedophilia absolutely unhinged tank no
not the king of late night he would
never do that hey story in five words
another hot teacher bangs student no
alarm this man is really about to be
like that would have been my dream no
2023.
alarming why are you going to me
first all right because because uh okay
this 38 year old math teacher in
California was once named teacher of the
year I support that was arrested a book
into jail for allegedly having sex with
a 16 year old male student she's posted
38 year old rape to 16 year old let's go
16 is the age of consent let's [__]
go everybody dude this is the most first
of all you know what the biggest crime
here is not not his advocacy for
pedophilia he just comes across very
French
this is the most French Greg Gutfeld has
ever come across unacceptable how do you
mean by that what do you mean this is
like
look up Emmanuel macaron's wife
I mean by that I don't know I'm not
familiar with that okay Emmanuel
macron's wife is literally this this is
what happened to uh macron and this is
macron's teacher his teacher this is
white yes oh well it worked out I always
like when when like pedophilia and
statutory rape stories turn into romance
yeah that's what by the way that's
Matthew
look at Woody Allen I mean he's married
to his [__] stepdaughter yeah that's
Magic by the way that is unironically
again what Matt Walsh advocates for when
he says like well there's a difference
between uh or Ben Shapiro has said this
as well and Tucker Carlson has said this
as well news flash every single
conservative has talked about how it's
fine to do statutory rape as long as
you're like getting married to them like
they advocate for child Brides all the
time because again they're [__]
freaks they're gross pedophile freaks
for the most part yeah so uh let's
continue
me
went to jail for it
whoa I've never heard that dude that's a
funny original take by the guy night I
you're telling me she should have got a
promotion okay so here's the thing
here's the thing here's the thing here's
the thing okay man if I was there I'd be
running train on her with all my buddies
like there are plenty of instant like I
was 16 once you know what I mean I I had
a hot teacher that I was like oh my God
it'd be so sick if I could have sex with
her thank God it never happened we don't
need cause I was [__] 16. okay we
don't need to explain why a 38 like
that's insane that's insane like you're
not Greg you're not 16 years old you're
not a 16 year old boy you [__] idiot
why are you arguing like you're a 16
year old boy well by the way the reason
that this even came out is because the
boy
oh oh yeah the boy told somebody yeah
oftentimes like very traumatic for uh
you know victims of statutory rape I
can't believe I'm saying yeah these
words I can't believe I'm explaining to
people that like Greg gutfelt is wrong
because that story rape laws exist for a
reason and by the way do you think this
room of of five total people anybody was
like
um little weird take there guys usually
no the the ladies usually are like
well they're usually just grossed out by
Greg Gutfeld like even when he's doing
the the they do he does like a like a
middle of the afternoon show before the
Jesse Waters show God damn it I watch
more Fox News than your grandma
um and on that show on that panel
there's always a guy uh there's always
either uh Greg uh Geraldo yeah that sits
on the second from the left next to
Judge Jeanine when she's on
um or a lady who is like supposed to be
the liberal person in the panel but
usually all of the women on the panel
are just like so grossed out by Greg
every time he talks like you can see
just like a natural like flinching
reaction to Greg's uh presence because
he's such a little Gremlin the guy who
let the air out of the tires of his no
Jesse Waters was that guy yeah that's
Jesse Waters he's like the classic
archetypical frat boy who's like I'm
kind of [__] stupid like uh but you
know
again the interesting thing here of
course is that their whole platform is
protecting kids against predators yet
here we are celebrating a 38 year old
having sex with a 16 year old who was
their student that's fantastic
60 year old guy would have died for that
yeah okay
again I am vehemently against banging
kids
okay Queen pop off I can't believe how
many times I've had to say that just
sitting in this chair well you know
you know you are you are a commentator
of Fox News so it kind of comes with the
territory you have you're gonna have to
keep saying that every day that you're
there girl there's like a couple things
every every uh uh female journalist
commentator at Fox News though he's got
to be swatting those dicks away because
sexual harassment is coming your way
okay this is the sexual harassment
Factory that you're working on I'm
surprised they hired a brunette to work
there frankly too no they it's called
diversity dog what do you mean that's
like the [__] but that's number one
you're gonna get you're gonna have to
swat as many dicks as possible okay and
then number two you're going to be
advocating against uh banging children
when your co-hosts are saying it's
actually fire as long as it's straight
As long as yeah because this always
reminds me no no as long as it's
straight and as long as the woman is the
rapist yeah yeah but this reminds me of
the the uh you know the age-old
uh Catholic Church being more upset
about homosexuality than the pedophilia
stuff right because there's nothing in
the Bible that says you can't [__] kids
is there
why are you looking at me I don't
[__] know well I'm just saying by the
way pretty sure I'm pretty sure it's
wrong and and I don't know because I
think as a matter of fact the the uh I
didn't read that [__] and the
Commandments thou shall not no no no I'm
pretty sure the the [__] the the
anti-lgbt provisions is actually about
child predation but they
don't have a problem with that but they
have a problem with the LGBT can you uh
PPT does it say anything about [__]
kids in the
and that good old Bible there
I've never had to say it any other time
that was the Van Halen song Hot for
Teacher that was written about wow I
don't know well no it wasn't my teacher
raped me no dude dude dude that's
awesome it was I have a crush on my
teacher which all all students do wait
okay okay okay the moment that you find
yourself using
any kind of rock music to defend your
argument you've lost like every single
[__] rock star from all the way from
like uh the 40s onwards has literally
had a song about [__] 14 year olds
okay are you insane why would you do
that you [__] freak
hey let's have a responsible
relationship with someone close to my
age
he's really dedicated to this point yeah
no this is like something he rides for
which is sad because he's like
probably uh you know I mean you just
don't expect that from a 100 gex fan
here's the thing
I just you know it really hurts to see
that like a gecker is is out here
[__] saying such gross [__] I think
there needs to be a quota that hot
teachers need to meet of of kids that
they're [__] okay it should be in
their contract
although yeah
all right
Autumn here you're a professor you deal
I think you you've dealt with talk oh
God way like this he's like oh no you
say that it is an unfair comparison it's
pretty easy you just say you're weird
and don't [__] kids like that it's like
an easy dub ah not when you're a
conservative also when he said you're a
professor I saw his his [__] shrink
eight sizes let's see because you know
little teacher like a male teacher 38
year old creepy female heroic
yeah unless of course you're disgusting
would you be okay with it if she
self-identified as 16.
he's a professor I see what is he a
professor of the professor of an idiot
like with these jokes
he's one of those
that's right Prager
yeah
[Laughter]
no I think I think it's borne out that
there is a difference between look I'm
not advocating
he's gonna have deep thoughts on this
sleep with their students particularly
if they're 16 17 18. but I do think that
there's a fundamental difference between
don't say it whether it's a man and a
woman a male and a female
they're saying this on TV
dude you know what saying this I for one
on Fox News I forgot hold on this
philosopher was just straight up like
it's okay for t a woman to rape a boy
that's not the same dude listen
he's following the French tradition baby
that's what he's doing my man said you
know
my man my man said we we this is like a
a philosopher on television advocating
for pedophilia is the most French thing
I've ever seen on Fox News
that's awesome
wow
it was like he is not going where I
think he's going with that now we're
we're constantly told that men and women
have to be equal and everything they're
cognitively equal emotional I'm sick of
pretending like men and women are equal
can we please keep raping the young boys
he did right he did write a book called
acting like it's the same thing he did
write a book called uh how to have
impossible conversations and I guess
this is you know maybe there was ab and
preach call it taboo subjects yes yeah
this is uh this is this is one of those
there's an age of consent challenge sick
of pretending like we're all the same
equal in strength for sports and I just
I just don't think I'm assuming he has
never uh been raped by a older woman
wait
he
he co-wrote that book with James Lindsay
who's James Lindsay let me Google that
you look stressed right now that's the
guy who was like critical James yeah
exceptional James yeah right conceptual
James right yeah yeah who's that uh
James is a rape Advocate
um an advocate for uh sex trafficking
nixium the cult yeah he was yeah yeah
here he is with Nikki Klein
mm-hmm
yeah there it is there there is our
there is our man conceptual James with
uh Nikki Klein who is a big defender of
the Nexium sex called and was one of the
main uh groomers in the next game sex
call so he wrote a pro rape book so it
adds up what your goals are a lot is pro
rape I don't know the context of this
book but I guess you could infer
yo I'm so glad this guy went to to got a
higher degree in philosophy I can tell
his mind is really a Nimble and and just
really able to take I'm telling man
listen listen no disrespect but you know
never ask a French philosopher what
their opinion is on Asia consent laws
okay when you learn about the great
philosophers of our time
Plato Socrates Delight that's not our
time that's not of our of our Western
age let's say okay not of our time all
right you know they talking about like
what's inside of a box can we know I you
know there there's these deep
fundamental ideas and here we have this
genius saying let's [__] more kids well
I'm curious if they'll bring it up on
the next uh Bill and sock uh podcast oh
yeah bill should ask about that actually
who's Bill soccer Bill uh Gates
Bill Gates in Socrates oh I saw that
that she was so I was [__] I don't
know they're coming for our jobs bro
yeah no we're we're cooked Socrates is
coming it's it's always funny the AI
guys are so [__] like
like I don't even I don't even want to
say they're all stem Lords because many
of them aren't but like
it's so obvious that they are they have
just like never
never been emotionally impacted by art
ever in their lives so they look at like
some of the dumbest [__] and go oh my
God look at how [__] insane this is
like this conversation between Bill
Gates and Socrates like oh it's really
gonna dramatically change everything
like that it was it was sucks it's bad
content yeah Bill uh bill was explaining
to Socrates what a laptop is yeah that
was pretty cool and he made a Macbook
joke Socrates did yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right let's turn this out but that
doesn't make it morally acceptable it
just means that there there are
differences yeah between men sleeping
with women and women sleeping yes the
other thing is finally older man
sleeping with a younger woman people
look at that different than an older
woman sleeping with a younger man no
that's true that's true yeah no that's
so true
what are you gonna say I agree with cat
like
you shouldn't the the idea that a
teacher is sleeping with such as young
student and it's just I you know what I
call someone like this feminist losers
the women are just missing the [__]
they just they're not getting it yeah no
she's an idiot hey um what would you
call someone like this he's a loser
feminist researcher who spends all her
Day on Reddit boards and thinks that's
research okay he nailed it nailed it
condone it
all right we're not creaking today
what is the creaking that's from their
videos you know if you notice all their
videos are super creaky bro I've never
watched a single video up from oh they
clipping that so you can never say that
no I
every single video
contention originally is that like I
didn't actually watch their videos and I
simply said I'm not interested in this
this seems transphobic I don't want to
get into a whole thing ah you a [__]
that was and I still I I stand by that
video
he's got you there hey bits and pieces
and that's it
oh did you know that they'd offended you
about that uh insane baseless uh
disproven accusation I know the person
who like literally lied about it I don't
want to bring it up I I don't want to
bring it up I know I know I know they're
up their toes and no I already told you
they're like oh them big time bro no
they are they are okay okay they're
they're they present themselves as
Centrist that's what I mean that's why
sometimes they have like reasonable
takes every now and then but
um
disagreements with them on the issue of
of trans people in general or what they
choose to spend most of their time on
you owe them
oh my teachers were so unattractive too
there's no way I would have sex yeah no
they weren't gonna [__]
[Laughter]
you're disgusting no you're [__] new
dog nobody's a little gremlin
yeah he is he is vile so there's Fox
News lots of fun having over there
they're hitting it they're asking the
hard questions and you got to respect it
they got philosophers on
we've perfected the Benny Johnson uh
flag that looks pretty good
so if you guys want to download this
let's tweet this out
so you guys can get the high uh res
photo of it
and so everybody's gonna have a picture
of this and so that Benny can appreciate
it uh and it's all of its Glory of
course
yeah
um
Let's see we got
Lil Ron
wait Pence is in yeah yeah I've
officially announced yet wait fence is
running it's happening Chris Christie
Chris Christie's gonna run too he's like
basically announced it but um you're
you're kidding the the latest one is uh
North Dakota governor who's like a
billionaire
um that's like
that was that was teased early this
morning
this is exciting Pence I I can't but
they have such a deep deep [__] deck
of people
and it's like it's so sad for little
Rhonda because every single person
that's not Trump
is going to take away possible votes and
possible dollars from Little Rhonda
because this is a this is a trump V
little around the campaign I mean this
is a trumpy little Rhonda how is Chris
Christie gonna show his face again after
this
Chris Christie at Roy Rogers at 11 PM in
the evening trying to console himself
wait tweeted that did he actually do
that God he's such a good poster
not even that long ago it was like it
was like October of last year dude
you're so bad as [__] by the way
dude that by the way being fat and fat
shaming other people who look exactly
like you is an American Pastime that's
true Trump just hides it better it's
just like it's always it always reminds
me of the dudes during covid
like dudes in Mississippi uh during
covet being like Oh that got that
because he's fat and I was like dude you
look exactly like him like you have the
same exact body type
um that Chris Christie does probably
need to switch up his style
um definitely the man is not he's just
not dressing well to his figure no I I
think like Chris okay I'm gonna disagree
with you here and here's why okay
disagree after you see this okay are you
gonna show the fupa the fupa actually
dude I know I've seen it already Okay go
ahead and I've seen this [__]
disagree with me at this moment okay I'm
disagreeing with you you want to know
why hold on because it's big boy season
I think
I think that hasn't it been big boy yeah
it has been I think there is a seismic
shift in American politics okay the days
of like the John Kelly Barack Obama
athletic presidents are gone it's a it's
a bygone era we don't want a guy like
George W bush who can throw a baseball
in a position
of power we want someone that resembles
the average American the average
American is very fat can I ask you
something what is he not wearing
underwear like what is going on down
there
I don't want to look at I'm not looking
I'm not going to zoom in on it because
that would be vulgar but I do have
questions
I think I think he's wearing underwear I
think he's tucking the belly into the
underwear
oh okay interesting my analysis that is
such I mean that's just the crime
honestly he he really [__] up
you've been fat your whole life how do
you not know never to do that like that
blows my mind who are you fooling
because like when you're fat and trust
me I know I've done this as well you
think maybe there's a certain level of
fat where you can like pull your belt
over your belly and like hide it a
little bit but like Chris Christie
you're way past that point my man why
are you doing that Trump has got it he
where's these huge suits you can't even
tell like what he what what's going on
under there at all you know yeah he's
hot it's like 20 foot like I want to
because he's sexy and I want to see
what's what what he's packing but so
Chris Christie has come back after that
uh I don't know how we've ever recovered
Pence is receiving Flack from Trump who
blames him for not stealing the election
for him but he's been relatively quiet
probably because he asked me because he
probably almost got him killed in my PO
em I don't think Trump gives a [__]
about that though yeah I don't think
he's threatened by Pence nobody's voting
for that cool
yeah literally what so here's the thing
okay every single guy that's like
running right now is running for very
obvious reasons one of two reasons
either a
they want a position in the cabinet
okay or B they just want like National
prominence and uh a paid vacation by
campaign donors okay that also dovetails
into a book tour they'll write a book
and uh you know that's it that's that's
literally what they're looking for
and okay that's interesting no that's
that's why they're doing it no one has
like a serious uh shot at unseating
Donald Trump what's what's surprising to
me is this
Ron DeSantis is the institutionalist guy
like he is the machine politics guy he
is the Republican party's guy right uh
when CPAC was happening and Trump was
there Ron DeSantis was down uh doing
like uh doing like a separate conference
with uh you know the coke donors uh the
the uh you know the Alec funders Branch
basically I forget exactly what the what
the counter uh uh conference that was
happening but Ron DeSantis is the guy
that is supposed to be the uh the guy
that's going to bring back civility
Insanity to the Republican Party while
still pushing their uh idiotic agendas
now
obviously that is a conundrum for
himself because most people care about
the Aesthetics of the culture war and
not necessarily the legislative agenda
of the culture War especially when like
half of that is really bad for the
broader population and it will actually
end up harming the Republican party down
the line electorally at least like we
saw with the abortion bans uh the
criminalization of abortion
but
Ron DeSantis ultimately is the
Republican party's guy so every single
other person that's running now is not
running against Donald Trump they're
running against Ron DeSantis so they're
kind of cooking him up a lot here
especially when he has 35 points to make
up against Donald Trump
yeah he's improved a little bit in
polling recently
but not it's not substantial maybe that
30 no instead of 35 but um
you know I've come to the conclusion
recently that
Ron descent is might be worse than Trump
I mean I think he is a more evil hateful
psychotic freak he's not than Trump he's
not dude he is a vile [__] creeper
Ron DeSantis is uh Rhonda Santos's uh
legislative agenda is the governor of
Florida is just uh triangulating to like
the the conservative commentator circuit
and the the loud gross weirdos on
Twitter like the idea that the broader
American voter base uh including like
moderate conservatives who just want tax
cuts and deregulation for their HVAC
businesses and whatnot but the idea that
they are like this invested in like
killing trans teenagers is silly it
doesn't show in the polls and it
certainly hasn't performed well for them
no he's just I think he just hates gay
and trans people no he's just I think
he's one of them no he's just the
Republican party's guy I think that's
what it is he's just the Republican
party's guy and his advisors are in his
ear telling him constantly to keep
beefing up this uh this strategy to keep
pushing this kind of [__] and the
greatest example is not even like the
anti-lgbt provisions the greatest
example of this is the six-week abortion
ban
Ron DeSantis looked at how undesirable
the abortion bans have been Across the
Nation and literally was so woefully
incapable of reading the [__] room to
save his goddamn life in his political
career that he thought no I'm just going
to lean into this as a matter of fact is
he being a politician or does he believe
in it because that that indicates he
believes in him no he's being a
politician if he was but he is he's
being no he's being a politician who is
unfortunately too hyper focused on
[__] losers like uh the the
Christopher Ruffo guy that's the problem
and a lot of Republicans in the party
think that like the reason why people
don't like Donald Trump is because he's
like uncivil they're behaving like
Democrats almost
um well the reason why people like
Donald Trump is because he's uncivil and
also because he doesn't push in areas
that he knows is unfavorable and and Ron
DeSantis is doing the exact reverse of
that where he doesn't have Donald Trump
sass he doesn't have Donald Trump's
Pizzazz his Charisma his RIS and on top
of that he's like literally pushing in
areas that will actually yield
electorally unfavorable outcomes for
himself running on uh cutting Social
Security and Medicare or like fiscal
responsibility which immediately signals
in a primary in a Republican primary uh
that you want to cut Social Security and
Medicare okay running on that is so
[__] bad in the post-trump world in
the Republican party you are literally
asking to get eviscerated to get
annihilated by Donald Trump in the
primary
he will never outflank Donald Trump on
the racism Spectrum he is the guy who
says it like it is he already well
established himself you will never
outflame
on trans and gay uh
hate he is he's the king of that no the
god of homophobia Donald Trump will just
say all hatred all gay people are child
molesters and everyone so thank you sir
anyway it's not happening to Santa's I
mean look at this it's not happening
okay
but here's his campaign uh announcement
and this guy sucks I mean this is [__]
dude
our border is a disaster our border is a
disaster federal government makes it
our border is a disaster
Mexicans are flooding in
hurting our families crime infestations
this [__] isn't on a border
state
he's not you're not even on a border
you you're the governor of Florida
our border is a disaster yes crime
infests our cities the federal
government makes it harder for families
to make ends families are hurting
president flounders but decline is a
choice success is attainable this man
has anti-riz I mean his voice like sucks
the enthusiasm and he does the bobble
head thing he was like oh he has got
like he's got the googly eyes bro it's
just so over
and freedom is worth fighting watch
writing the ship requires a freedom is
worth fighting for unless you get a
chance restoring sanity to our society
oh normalcy to our community and
integrity his gay attitude is not is not
must be our foundation and Common Sense
can no longer be an uncommon virtue in
Florida pause it pause it this is people
to judge you are the Elizabeth Warren of
the Republican party oh the idea that
you're doing word salad like this is so
[__] dumb who are you signaling to
the base of the Republican Party are the
schizophrenic Psychopaths who think
Satan has infiltrated the schools okay
you ran towards that base the Republican
party did for years and years and years
you can't turn around and be like common
sense is uncommon nowadays I'm running
to restore sanity what are you Hillary
Clinton who the [__] who the [__] how is
this good campaign how is it a good
campaign announcement how
I don't like I'm running to restore
sanity is quite literally verbatim What
Democrats who are inevitably going to
fail say okay I love it prove that it
can be done we chose facts over fear
education over indoctrination Law and
Order over rioting and disorder we held
the line when Freedom hung in the
balance we showed that we can and must
Revitalize America yes we need the
courage to lead and the strength to win
yes I'm Ron DeSantis and I'm running for
president to lead our Great American
comeback you know what I'm oh look at
that convincing smile wait hold on no no
it gets worse that smile is like giving
me Herman Cain
oh God bro has never smiled before I
think he's so uncomfortable look at this
so
one of the first things he said in his
campaign announcement was that he's
running to restore sanity it's time to
announce your running mate holy [__]
that'd be oh yeah yeah gross go ahead
sorry I just had to read that
he can't uh you can't be vice president
if you're not an American citizen I'm
pretty sure hell right well he's a
citizen but he's well no no no I said
yeah you have to be boring do it you
need to be born in the United States
thank [__] God okay
he seems to be trying to trick people
into thinking that that might be a
possibility
well I mean Republicans have done this
before and so did the Democrats Barack
Hussein Obama hold on hold on
isn't Ted Cruz Canadian what is that all
about
uh Ted Cruz was born in Canada wasn't he
I don't think he was no no he was uh I
I'm pretty sure he was it doesn't matter
yeah he was born in Canada it doesn't
matter if your parents are American
citizens uh or you're born in like a U.S
military base
right it's the it's the same thing with
John McCain because he was born not on
U.S soil yeah he was and Dan Crenshaw
too right I think okay um
yeah that doesn't matter you know what
does matter though is uh [__] Mitt
Romney's dad was literally born in
Mexico
and I'm pretty sure it wasn't even like
a a natural-born U.S citizen was
actually naturalized
so but mitt was born in USA yeah I know
but George Romney also ran for president
oh his dad yeah so what wait so we just
ignore that rule despite not [__]
being born in the country that's
interesting
so what you're saying is there's hope
for Elon yeah it's not count him out no
elon's parents are not American citizens
who cares and and neither was Romney's
parents
you know how much money he has uh do
whatever the [__] he wants George
Romney's parents moved to Mexico or his
great grandparents maybe moved to Mexico
because they wanted to keep doing uh uh
Paulie [__] well here is my favorite
part that we were deprived of talking
about last week because I had to cancel
because of my throat
um Elon and Ron
teamed up for the spectacular uh Twitter
announcement this was huge uh he was
exclusively launching his campaign via
Twitter
and uh
it was it was spectacular
foreign
has since defended this by the way
saying Well everybody's talking about so
how is it this A Loss interesting
now let's go ahead
all right this is this is edited by the
way they are long gaps of Silence yeah
like 10 minutes at a time yeah this is
condensed but it is this is an Acura
portrayal yes I would say so we just
didn't want I just don't have to be
sitting here for 10 minutes at a time in
the absolute sideways sure I love this
this is my favorite thing of the year
and wherever in the world you're joining
us from I'm broadcasting live from David
from Twitter headquarters it's David sax
here Elon is sitting next to me and we
want and we want to welcome you to this
historic Twitter spaces
in the history of social media uh
tonight I'm pleased to introduce two
individuals who've done more to loosen
the
yeah all right sorry about that we we've
got so many people here that I think we
are by the way it wasn't that many it
was like 200 000. so at first it it went
all the way up to like I think 500 to
600 000 but like it doesn't matter
because it was bricked from the start
and uh everybody called it myself
included that it was going to fail
inevitably
um it's not that many every social media
can run that no [__] issue exactly
500 000 is is that's just child exactly
which is precisely why this was there's
so many people here and we're completely
moved on and then then they moved it on
to David Sax's account right and then it
was fine it was started working and it
and it cut down to 200 000 people and at
that point it was still awful because
one there's no there's no visuals okay
um so that's a ridiculous way to
announce to begin with and two they
mostly just glazed Elon like Elon was
running or something they were just
congratulating themselves as well wait
his video he had this launch video that
was like 75 about Elon yeah right that
was what I was referring to when he
seems to be trying to someone is that
right here yeah I believe it's the next
link okay so I want to enjoy this we are
uh kind of melting the servers uh which
is a good sign
um that is not a good sign for you at
all that's 200 000 people like I'm
pretty sure I could host 200 000 people
in my Discord uh [__] it
of members chat yeah all right I'd like
to just introduce the the uh the folks
in in the room here so it's safe to say
we wouldn't be making history without
demands I could host more people in My
World of Warcraft 3 land Lobby dude I
have had that many people uh on on my
stream uh when we did the AOC uh
collaborative Among Us stream there was
more people than that like it was
perfectly fine it's ridiculous to think
that uh you know no other website could
host something like this you have to be
a total [__] idiot to think that that
is the case hold on breaking news Chris
chungus is taking the lead oh
oh hell yeah I am I am a a big boy
supporter I myself I'm a big boy I I
think that it's good Ron DeSantis is
like trying to lose weight and I think
that uh that is going to inevitably hurt
him in the polls uh ozempic Ron get the
[__] out of here oh you know what I like
is a Ron disaster I think that is good
because it hits a disc like a big part
of his name anyway let's keep I wanna I
wanna we're getting low on time and I
really genuinely want to listen to this
Elon Musk his decision to purchase this
platform last year for ReStore to its
original Mission as a beacon for free
speech and even to expose Twitter's
complicity with a government-centered
regime might have surprised many but not
those of us who've known to work with
Elon for nearly a quarter centuries
Elite institutions in corporate media uh
go ahead and send a heart up if you want
to say thank you Elon let's get those
hearts in Governor DeSantis first Drew
my attention and support when I saw how
he responded to the covet pandemic and
refused to believe what we now know to
be the many falsehoods that government
experts their media mouthpieces were
feeding us he kept Florida schools open
and it's economy thriving while my state
of California chose two years of
learning loss and lockdowns that we have
yet to full
yeah this bye bye
he was he was doing so good we're back
yeah I think so
um just to simplify that I think we're
just gonna use
every time
yeah yeah so let's see so I think it's
keep crashing
yeah that's another that's another thing
that I love these candid moments another
thing that I think is bad for DeSantis
is he constantly talks about like I
saved Florida during the shutdowns I
didn't allow the state to close down and
it's like brother that is the worst
[__] campaign cry that you could have
because
absolutely no one wants to think about
covid so you constantly relitigating
covid is like only going to signal to
either a the uh the on the liberal side
of the spectrum people who are still
like covet is still a very real reality
which it is okay certainly and people
who are still masking or uh which is a
tiny fraction of the liberal side and
they're going to despise you for
constantly talking about how you kept it
open or B the [__] absolute freaks
the only people that still talk about
covet non-stop are the freaks on the
right who are like remember coven they
made our children gay but they made it
yeah like we gotta fight fauji like no
one wants to think about kovid no one
wants to think about that time that was
like whether people recognize it or not
it's still relatively traumatic for most
people
yeah I mean he already got his props for
that it's it's ancient history yeah
bringing that back is constantly just
like reminding people of of covet you
don't want to be associated with that
right so it's um service restraining
somewhat
um
whispering
Elon doesn't know he's playing
sir it's live
yeah it's live right now
um
all right we're just uh reallocating
more uh server capability uh to be able
to handle load here it's uh hold on I'm
on Amazon servers right now I'm trying
to buy some more space real quick we
downsized everything
they're really going going crazy so
um yeah wait are there their floors
um
uh make us uh
oh
does Santa still have not said a word to
um yeah well let's see so yeah Governor
there's been a lot of speculation over
the last couple of months about your
your plans
um I understand that you may have an
announcement to make uh we've got I
think a record audience assembled here
uh you know probably the biggest
uh room that's probably ever been
assembled online uh what would you like
to tell them the biggest room I am
running for president of the United
States to lead our Great American
comeback look we know they're like get
it out quick get it out quick our
country's going in the wrong direction
we see it with our eyes and we feel it
in our bones Southern borders collapse
drugs are pouring into the country our
cities are being hollowed out by spiking
crime the federal government's making it
harder for the average family to make
ends meet and to attain and maintain a
middle-class lifestyle and our thing
that he said that's the end of the tech
once you came on okay the thing that
he's hitting on is stuff that like I
don't even really see
even plausible like crimes in big cities
I don't think crime is up in big cities
it's not and that narrative clearly
flubbed when uh it didn't work during
the midterms when every every [__]
Outlet was only talking about it like no
crime oh my God crime is crazy crime is
crazy it's not and it only worked a
little bit in like Democrat cities where
Democrats actually capitulated to that
but
um but even then it was not that they're
thinking of like in San Francisco you
remember how there's all these videos of
people like going into Walgreens and
grabbing [__] yeah well I guess that I
mean they were they were using that
quite effectively
um and then the other thing is like
immigration just
got totally boned because of the title
41 or whatever title 42 yeah got
canceled so like there's not crazy
amounts of immigration going on
and I just I I don't even know what what
these uh I don't know what he's on about
I don't think those are good topics to
hit on
thank you for listening to my TED Talk
all right finally let's just do one more
this is his campaign launch video
I think it's about him becoming
president or or it's about how cool Elon
Musk is I frankly can't tell this and I
was flabbergasted by this yeah and I I
was unsure it was it's so amateurish
what we're about to see that I thought
maybe it was just like a supporter or
some sort of outside group yeah yeah no
this is his his campaign yeah this is
worm made this issue Elon is not running
as his vice president then
I
i i i
this it's like mentals illness I don't
know I mean watch this
well I am running for president of the
United States okay so first they're
using this horrible [__] audio from
the Twitter from the Twitter space
American comeback we know our country's
going in the wrong direction we see it
with our eyes and we feel why is Elon
our Southern borders collapse why is
Elon
in your announcement video you along
with the flamethrower especially when
he's talking about one of my favorite
Parts is like when he's talking about
illegal immigrants pouring through our
borders and it's just Elon Musk he's one
of them he is one of the illegal
immigrants I mean technically he is a
Visa overstayer right although if you
want to if you really want to talk about
immigration then I think Elon Musk is a
pretty good case that immigrants come
here and uh are contribute a lot to
society I mean he's you know what I mean
uh in his case that's that's debatable
but immigrants do great stuff out here
in our in our country drugs are pouring
into the country our cities are being
hollowed out by why why is this
yeah again he is signaling to uh a a
general voter audience a general voter
base like the the general election uh
voter population that he is going to be
the reasonable
uh he's going to be the reasonable
candidate like the one that can actually
uh unite uh all of the different
constituencies under the Republican
Banner
um except he needs to make it out of the
primary and for that he needs to be like
incredibly far right
and he needs to be incredibly far out
with his rhetoric and be able to defend
that not by actually pushing harmful
legislation because nobody ultimately
cares about that harmful legislation
nobody thinks that that's great that
it's happening
this is elod's contribution by the way
so it's debatable I guess maybe we
should end immigration I don't know
[Music]
harder for the average family to make
ends meet and to attain to maintain a
middle-class lifestyle and our president
oh he looks so much in the face of our
nation's challenges and he takes his
cues from the woke mob I don't think it
has to be this way American decline is
not inevitable it is a this part like
why why do you keep showing you correct
it's like these weird subliminals
especially the dance moves like the one
where he's like like it's like what are
you doing like when they flash pictures
of like like [__] to make you gay or
something or they flash quick pictures
of like Oh you mean [__] Hypno this is
a [__] this is a [__] Hypno
porno Elon Musk porn for sure it is
for sure a path that will lead to
American revitalization oh [__] we must
read breaking news Biden just [__]
ate dirt
let's hope he doesn't end up in the dirt
from that fall
breaking news
[Music]
oh [__] oh no see we could oh no we
cannot let him fall that that that that
that's how people his age died oh no no
dude that's it he he's [__] hit
literated brother it's over that's
sawdust his ass is sawdust he can't even
get up on his own oh his bone his bones
just turned to gelatin oh no
I love the cheering going on
[Applause]
you know this is this right here is
going to be an every Biden attack ad
that Trump makes the next year and a
half I initially found it on Rumble
okay oh yeah the only honest website out
there right that's right he was blaming
something on the floor do we blame it
let's see he point out something on the
floor
[Applause]
[Music]
he's doing and it [__] owned oh you
know you know what I'll say for for a
man's age a banana peel actually very
deadly no it was a uh it was a green uh
uh turtle shell
um he did fall somewhat gracefully for a
person his age you know well I won't
take that away from I mean he's like 90.
he'll be fine
before sanity to our nation this means
embracing fiscal and economic sanity
stop pricing hard-working America
and spending policies and please I love
American Energy Independence this also
means I'm just going to mute him I mean
what the [__]
uh I would love to the funniest part a
ratio of how long Elon is on the screen
to how long I think it's 50 50. is it
really I can't it is 50 50. I cannot
comprehend one of the main things I
cannot comprehend here is uh other than
that footage why did they use the audio
from the spaces dog why did you do that
why didn't you do a rewrite why didn't
you do a reread why didn't you mic this
hand this up separately so that you
could have clear audio you [__]
idiots who's running this goddamn
campaign what is this this is a dog and
pony show
but with actual dogs and ponies no
there's a dog
so I I'd be down for Elon Musk VP that'd
be interesting
you know I'm in [__] it let's go we
don't care because no Trump turning on
on no I don't care about that Trump
turning on Elon would be really
entertaining well that's already kind of
happened because he give him the big
middle finger I'm not coming back to
Twitter mask off Phil hasn't come back
no no mask off Trump supporters versus
uh Trump I mean it'd be a bloodbath no
no no no yeah so that's it
no no no that's about it eh I think
that's about it what's there left to say
ah 69. it's the worst month of the year
I said I'll say oh [__] I forgot never
mind I'm actually not a foe anymore I
love the Ally June is my favorite pride
month
June is my favorite month not just
because of pride month but it's my
birthday it's my son's birthday oh then
it's you have a gay birthday then yes
happy gay birthday thank you and it's
and it's when summer starts when
everybody gets off school June is the
best month in my opinion
they gave the best month to the gays
I think July is a little better but July
is Todd it's lame I I like July 2 which
is my birthday month July
Bingo baby answer gang hold on
July is not better than June yes it is
yes it is you just said because you just
said school's ending in June but yeah
it's ending but that means there's still
school I don't know yeah July in July
baby full Freedom baby it's the act and
and what's the most Freedom holiday for
the Fourth of July 76 baby I don't know
it's the feeling of the freedom you get
when it's over how about the feeling of
freedom I get in my bones on the fourth
of July is it what's a better month June
or July well I just want to say real
quick uh Olivia's birthday is in July so
just another point
it's not about better month
June Theodore's birthday is in June so
if you all want to vote against him then
you're gonna wow
to form votes yeah I'm just telling it
like it is I'm voting you hate my son if
you vote for that's crazy just saying it
like if you hate America
mom and dad and apple pie
wow it's close pretty close yeah pretty
close June a little ahead but um
miserable
let's go July gang baby July game okay
it's in June this year yeah thank you
June June June June June Jordan Jordan
Peterson loves you June June
June and that's all you need to know you
are you in support of Jordan Peterson I
think not right no but we can all agree
on certain things okay June is the best
month me and Jordan
Ethan Ethan I'm with you oh it's the
start of summer it's the start of summer
it's the feeling hold on the feeling
first of all you [__] 50 50 50. you
okay no it's back in June no July listen
and I'm talking to Amy
okay I'm getting a little uncomfortable
it just sounds like Jordan's saying Jew
over and over again making me scared
when school and Jews and you go on to
Summer that is that you can't beat that
feeling in July you can't beat that
feeling anyway
July is halfway point that the fun is
halfway done and you're like I gotta go
my ass is going back and by the way no
July's the peak and by the way by the
way it's the the all the school in June
rules because you know it's coming to an
end it's cool yeah finals no no no no no
yeah oh God okay let me ask you guys
this what's your favorite Friday
Saturday or Sunday what's your favorite
day
is the best
because
you wake up at a reasonable time and
then the next day uh is also Sunday so
you still got more yeah
Friday night Friday night World ahead of
you exactly
because objectively works on Saturday
then the tomorrow's Sunday baby yeah
Friday is everything who are these who
are these June voters in our audience
they're just they're they're ridiculous
I'm with Ethan on this oh my goon is
better it's better
thank you I don't even I don't even know
you people July July July it's like yeah
what do you love about July I will say
Hassan saying July is Peak did get me
thinking though like
what's the best moment when you're
coming or like leading up to it no I'm
not talking about organs I'm talking
about like drugs that's a question for
soccer
people like the act of having sex and
then when you come it's done right what
do you mean but like the whole that's
the goal that's the
goals are not about the destinations
about the journey bro Amen to that L
it's at the journey explanation that
makes the journey worth it when you're
when you're coming all right well argue
harder because 53 say June yeah no we
lost this one I I I will have to admit
it's all about this it's a bad point you
know what it was the friends that we
made along the way and June July is
still happening in July June shouldn't
happen again true king right and that's
a good thing because I had school in
June so [__] that well I don't know why
they held your ass in June in June why
do you like July so much it's also my
birthday month okay yeah okay this is
the real political divide in this
country that's right it's not rural
voters versus Urban voters uh someone
says October is a good month I agree
with that too at November
I mean what no summer months are goated
like way better come on I mean I like I
like I don't mind the [__]
now I like winter October November combo
rules interest
ing hey it's okay okay you know I'm not
gonna knock it but it's it's no July
fall is great
it's a bad pole Ethan rigged it
everybody knows it bye-bye yes dude yes
how are you gonna talk [__] on fall like
well who are you no one's [__] [__]
it's just it's the weather is better
than June pumpkin spice lattes Dan
not a fan I know beautiful I know we
have so much to look forward to through
the year with all these beautiful months
thank you uh I just had a birthday but
it wasn't my 21st it was my 30th uh Zach
thank you thank you for being honest
[__] you 21 nine you gotta get one for
each number so you can add it up
and give them a shout out for it's 21
plus nine
can we work on that sure we gotta find
Aiden Ross saying each number if you
guys can pull that I think that'd be
awesome all right maybe I'm saying Plus
yeah that'd be good all right listen
everybody what a show we've had
I think we've done we've gone a long way
to curing the sickness of this nation
and I can only thank Target
for purging itself of the Demonic
presence
of the colorful rainbow
because as you know we want drab colors
we want only gray skills for our kids to
wear
only gray skills
just like Stalin monitors you know
colors are for demon colors of a demon
there is nothing there's nothing gear
than talking about the Aesthetics of
certain colors which is what all of
these like anti-lgbt bigots do on a
regular basis so welcome welcome also I
want to say that I'm undergoing eye
surgery to remove color
from my icons I will be only seeing in
grayscale now as a protest against
practice
these glasses have changed my life I am
protesting I will be doing permanent
damage to my eyes to remove color
you're a warrior dude that's what the
[__] solidarity is and now I won't even
see rainbows when pride comes around I
won't even know
I'll be living in in ignorance is bliss
my parents you vaccinated yourself
also you can go to I you can go to
igbt away.com and use code H3 to get
your eye grayscale surgery
exclusive sponsor
don't do it here's why if you can't see
the colors you will never know who's
trying to queerify your children oh do
you think it's mine he's working with
the Enemy that is a problem sabotage
yeah okay how about this
let's make sure all kids and people at
that we need to a gray plain uniform
that we all wear so that we don't ever
have to see colors and rainbows again
and by accident some people go outside
they're wearing rainbows by accident now
that makes me gay too so even The
Accidental rainbow is a problem which is
why I'm pitching today that in addition
to eye surgery we're gonna wear gray
uniform outfits men children babies
alike even the Dead the recently
deceased uh to avoid
any possibility of seeing a rainbow
thank God thank God we got to the bottom
of this thank God we addressed this
great great uniforms for men women and
children huh perhaps some sort of patch
to identify which one of those groups
sure yeah yes I like the idea of a arm
flare just simply because yeah
[Music]
like interacting and commingling with
like normal people you know what I mean
so like you gotta probably put a patch
on them right something like this I'm
imagining um oh boy you know uh
something that sounds it sounds it looks
great oh okay something like this I
thought it was gonna be it's like like
Ramstein way darker uh something like uh
I typed 1984 uniform I don't know why
they're giving me such I love the
Ghostbusters yeah why is that there well
because that movie came out in 1984 I
think Oh that's come on you you could
you're better than that Google 1980
they're not they're really not you're
trying to make your children gay too
yeah
here this is what I'm I bet if you click
on the Google this is how we need to be
click on the Google uh uh page right now
let's see what this is you know the
doodle you think the doodle is dude even
if there's no Doodle look it's white
right now right wait whoa honoring pride
is right here whoa well they didn't
rainbow it
Google normally has all the colors of
the rainbow automatically and they
decided not to do it specifically for
Pride whoa you're right we won folks
hold on hold on Google is straight let's
go Incognito and then go to google.com
no I think they ah it was
it was the there's something going on
with that bro look at those colors Ethan
don't you see it as the rainbow I'm
gonna click honoring Pride so
uh divert your eyes people
oh
it could be yeah
it did look like that
what do we do about it I never look at
circles the same ever again
ruined me nothing
all right guys have a great uh evening
tomorrow is the best day of the week as
we've all noted here today
we got a great show tomorrow which uh is
going to be a welcome departure from our
usual Friday shows yes and um I look
forward to seeing you guys there Hassan
thank you for being here thank you for
having me
nice to see you after our short break
hidea
bring your dog next week stop being a
hater and just
you know I mean I have my dogs here they
love just let her bark through the whole
episode
[Music]
all right she'll be fine it has
character who cares people don't care if
she yeah
all right guys
oh Skittles Corporation what are we
gonna do about it
that's what we need to do about that's
next week's episode we'll preview next
week okay bye everybody
[Music]